oh this is this is great learn more  about the topics that interest them we  have a responsibility to increase access  to good information good information  decreasing the bad to make sure that  we're doing that we tackle  misinformation on our platform based on  what we call four hours of  responsibility we remove the most  harmful content that violates our  policies we reduce recommendations of  borderline content we raise up  authoritative sources for news and  information and we reward trusted  creators and artists you can learn more  about how we enforce our policies in a  separate video but the bottom line is  that we aim to enforce our community  guidelines consistently using a  combination of machine Learning Systems  content reviewers and user reports to  detect review and remove content that  crosses the line  we strive to remove content that  violates our policies before it's widely  viewed or viewed at all